[Music]
what are your superpowers
just um just like Superman it well
that's crazy right what are your
superpowers superpowers dude I don't
even know how to pee in this thing okay
why are you talking you're dead your
window welcome for not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie so we got some
new Shazam to break down and Zachary
Levi has been talking more about
crossing Shazam as a character over with
the next version of the Justice League
so we have actually pretty good idea
what that new version of Justice League
is gonna look like based on all the
recent announcements so we'll break it
down there's a new round of the I max
take a giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this and you know
really good news people asking when are
we gonna get even more new footage we
actually found out about that too so
obviously the focus of this latest
footage is just Superman shout outs like
they literally talk about Batman
Superman in the Justice League
constantly during the Shazam movie
Freddie Freeman is the superhero fanboy
of that family so he has all those
collectibles that he's picked up he has
the Batarang from Batman V Superman he
has the bullets that bounced off of
Superman during that movie when Batman
was trying to take him down in this
scene here so even though Ben Affleck
has announced that he's leaving his
Batman is still a very big presence
during this Shazam movie now it'll be
really different when we see the next
version of Batman in the next Justice
League movie I think when we get to
stuff like that is where they'll play it
a little fast and loose with the
continuity because some of the
characters from the DC Universe
obviously will be sticking around like
Jason Momoa and gal gadot just because
their franchises are doing really really
well Jason Momoa surprisingly now has
the highest grossing DC movie of all
time
he actually made more money than the
Dark Knight that is crazy so of course
they're gonna be making a ton more
Aquaman movies there was even reported
Henry Cavill cameo that they had planned
for Shazam but just the scheduling
didn't work out and Henry Cavill was
still negotiating with Warner Brothers
to extend his Superman contract then
last year you may have heard the press
reporting that the studio was saying
that they weren't gonna do another
Superman movie anytime soon they were
gonna do a Supergirl movie and focus on
her the reason why you shouldn't get
triggered with news like that is because
what the studio is doing is they're just
using the press to negotiate with Henry
Cavill so even though his camp came out
and said a whole bunch of stuff don't
pay too much attention to all that kind
of drama there was something that Geoff
Johns said a little while ago that was
really candid before he left the
official Warner Brothers post to start
producing the Green Lantern Corps movie
an interviewer was asking him what's the
deal with the next Man of Steel movie
we want our next Superman movie and this
was happening when they were starting to
reshuffle all their movies and change
all their plans and people were getting
fired so he was actually being really
candid about this when he said the
studio understands the importance of
Superman they have not forgotten so you
read between the lines and what that
means is is that yes the studio
definitely does want to do more Superman
Man of Steel movies but I think the
problem is is that that's such a big
swing for them and they spent so much
money on the Aquaman movie it was a huge
gamble if they'd had another disaster
after Justice League it would have been
catastrophic to the studio so I think in
reality they didn't want to take a
gamble that big and they wanted to try a
couple smaller movies of smaller budgets
before they double down on a Superman
Man of Steel movie and also they wanted
the dust to clear a little bit from all
those Justice League characters just
because people remember Justice League
so much but he give it a couple years
and people will stop thinking about it
quite as much especially with a couple
really strong movies under their belt so
I think they're just waiting until they
have a couple of really big hits before
they go back to the Superman well but
all you have to do to see the Henry
Cavill still really wants to be Superman
is just check out his Instagram account
he posts Superman pictures all the time
and he is way more Jack now doing his
Witcher workouts whatever he's gonna
look like in full costume and that first
Witcher trailer is gonna be crazy
compared to what he looked like during
the Man of Steel movie I think that's
his most jacked right now look you talk
about levels of Henry Cavill like he had
slimmed down a little bit during Justice
League because he was filming that
Mission Impossible movie and he wasn't
supposed to be quite as big for that but
back during Man of Steel era he went way
over the top because it's like oh this
is the first version of Superman that
anybody's seen in a long time so he has
to be huge so as accurately by talking
about Shazam effectively confirmed that
it is going to be a while before they do
their next Justice League film but the
plan is to put Shazam in that movie
because it'll feel very different
because so much time will have gone by
in the left cycled a couple of the other
big Justice League actors at present
this is what that team is gonna look
like so Ben Affleck just did that big
interview I did a video for it where he
officially confirmed no more Batman
appearances in any movies so that
actually answers a lot of questions for
other cameos and other people's movies
as well
can now say that Matt Reeves version of
Batman unless something really goes
wrong with that movie that Batman in
present day will join the next version
of Justice League presumably his sequel
movies will move into present-day the
way that Wonder Woman's movies start out
set during the past like Wonder Woman
1984 is the sequel then Wonder Woman 3
is gonna be set during present day
enough time will have gone by that will
have seen two of Matt Reeves Batman
movies with whoever that new actor winds
up being I know there's a lot of rumors
about who they're gonna cast for Batman
we probably won't hear about that till
at least comic-con maybe a little bit
after that we'll also have enough time
to see the Black Adam solo movie so
they'll debut the rock as Black Adam
within the DC Universe and probably
enough time for them to have a Shazam
versus Black Adam movie before he joins
the Justice League so we're talking at
least four to six years for that next
Justice League movie but gal gadot will
still have time to do obviously Wonder
Woman 1984 the 3rd Wonder Woman film in
present day we'll have seen Aquaman 2
and that trench spin-off movie probably
not enough time to get a 3rd Aquaman
movie out that's probably gonna take a
little bit longer the flash is another
big question mark right now right now
they're currently scheduled to start
shooting the flash movie next year but
because it keeps getting delayed because
Ezra Miller is part of that fantastic
beast franchise and they're making a
billion of those movies and Warner
Brothers seems to be prioritizing him in
those over his Flash movie if for some
reason they delay the flash movie again
and it does not start filming next year
I'm totally fine with them recasting
Ezra Miller and just completely
redesigning what the flash looks like
what his costume looks like the way he
moves the Speed Force within the DC
Universe does brand new actor a brand
new look they do one of those movies and
then they do the second movie after
whatever the next Justice League movie
is if you are a really big fan of the
flash as a character by that time we'll
have also probably seen a version of a
speedster on Titans but I guess think
that would be a new version of Wally
West or Bart Allen who we haven't seen
in any live-action version yet Bart
would actually be a pretty solid choice
because I don't think that they're gonna
do him on the flash TV show right now
but here's the other big thing - they
wait to do that next Justice League
movie until they do the Green Lantern
Corps movie so we get Hal Jordan and
they can bring in more big cosmic stuff
from the DC Universe it doesn't really
make sense unless you have a lot of
cosmic characters on your
so don't forget that we also have a New
Gods movie that's coming up in the next
couple of years enough time will have
gone by that will have already seen that
but based on all the confirmed news that
we've gotten about it it's relatively
self-contained and the main characters
are mr. miracle and big Barda it's
mostly like a love story between the two
of them a bit of a heist film in the
main villains are granny goodness in the
female Furies if you guys are really
familiar with the New Gods characters or
big Barda and mr. miracle stories read
Tom Kings mr. miracle comic book it is
probably one of the best comic books in
the last ten years the basic premise of
their relationship is is that big Barda
is one of the most badass female Furies
she's in love with mr. miracle who's one
of the New Gods but it's sort of this
West Side Story type of thing where you
have rival gangs where two of them are
in love with each other on opposing
sides granny goodness doesn't want to
have any of that because big Barda is
supposed to be loyal to her so she sets
the female Furies to go and try and
bring her back and force her to rejoin
the team so you sort of that mr. miracle
trying to pull these giant heists on
dark side and then granny goodness and
the female Furies trying to stop them so
even though the new guys are crazy
powerful characters compared to the
people that you would beat on planet
Earth
I think it's gonna be a relatively
smaller self-contained story you do like
a smaller Justice League post-credit
scene during that and set up the idea
that they'll eventually cross those
characters over but hopefully that kind
of explains what the plan is right now
but just remember that because that's
like 4 to 6 years down the road worth of
DC movies then a lot of stuff can change
and I know that doesn't really answer a
lot of questions about what's gonna
happen to cyborg I do not think that
they're gonna make that cyborg solo
movie what'll probably happen is as the
redesign what he looks like a little bit
and they'll put him in some of the
appropriate movies so that by the time
we get to that next Justice League movie
you're very familiar with who he is what
his personality is and what his
relationships are like with the other
Justice League characters like they
could turn him into the next Coulson of
the DC Universe even if he's not gonna
be a really big solo movie character so
let me know in the comments Shazaam
joins the Justice League in like 4 to 6
years who do you want the villain of
that movie to wind up being if they're
not going to do like a big New Gods
character the Legion of Doom would
probably be the logical choice if they
want to stay on earth be
then you can include any number of big
crossover characters like Black Manta in
the actor who plays Black Manta in the
Aquaman movie did say that he had a
contract to appear in other DC movies
but he didn't say what those movies were
going to be for those of you asking when
we're gonna get more Shazam trailers the
big news is is that we're gonna get more
footage when they drop Aquaman on home
video that's March 3rd so at least by
then but because that doesn't leave a
lot of time before the movie actually
comes out there will be another trailer
between now and then so don't be
surprised if you get some surprise
footage in the next couple of weeks
usually it winds up being Tuesday
mornings when they drop new trailers so
just look out for that whatever ends up
happening I will totally make videos for
it but leave your requests in the
comments below
congratulations mo Bosa you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here for my last really
big Shazam black Adams Superman trailer
video and click here for my non-spoilery
early Captain Marvel review thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]